It's quite rare to be able to... Oh! Computer, lock the door.
I am going to show you how to make the perfect champagne cocktail.
A tricorder is always quite handy 'cause you need to check the standard ingredients...
...to make sure they're within normal parameters.
Right. We take some sugar and put it in the champagne glass.
A few dashes of Angostura Bitters. That is perfect.
A little dash of brandy in there. That will warm things up.
See that layer there? Just a little bit of a layer?
Ease the cork out. We don't want it to... Oh!
That is so wrong.
You got to have your thumb in the little dimple at the bottom of the glass and... Oh!
I'm feeling a little bit tiddly.
Oh! I'm a responsible adult.
I can't wait any longer. I'm gonna have to just...
I could fall in love with this.
This is the perfect 'Captain's Cocktail.'
Make it so.